on vient de la prendre il y a quelques
minutes dans la presse Pierre Palmade a
été libéré de sa détention provisoire il
y a pile une semaine la cour d'appel de
Paris avait décidé de l'envoyer en
prison il n'y aura finalement pas en
tout cas pas pour le moment il avait été
placé en détention privée à l'hôpital et
il est donc simplement sous contrôle
judiciaire à l'hôpital du plaisir au
moisson il a été transféré on parlait il
y a quelques minutes sur son transfert
on va revoir son transfert avec les
images de son de son escort et vous
allez nous donner les infos aussi de son
escort parce que on se demandait
pourquoi ils étaient autant pour Pierre
Palma regarde
tout juste d'arriver ici au sein de
l'hôpital Marie Lannelongue au
Plessis-Robinson il était à bord d'une
ambulance escortée par la police si moto
et deux voitures va suivre un traitement
de 48 heures l'établissement est
spécialisé dans la chirurgie du thorax
des vaisseaux et du cœur il dépend donc
de l'administration pénitentiaire de
Fresnes une détention provisoire qui se
poursuit donc ici au sein de l'hôpital
Marie Lannelongue car les médecins
estiment que pour le moment son état de
santé n'est pas compatible avec une
incarcération dans une maison d'arrêt
alors ça vient de tomber pourquoi ton
escorte pour Pierre Palmade
système pyramidal tout le monde a peur
de tout donc on se couvre au maximum
parce que honnêtement qui qui va
attaquer Pierre Palmade et il est en
tout cas pas en état de s'évader
visiblement donc je pense qu'une
ambulance avec de motard aurait
largement suffit ça aurait été comment
pour une personne lambda c'était quoi
une on sait de moteur à une ambulance en
fait de motard si il y a une urgence à
se déplacer pour se faire ouvrir la
route mais sinon l'ambulance l'ambulance
par elle-même est suffisante
Marylène longue c'est un hôpital
spécialisé pour les pathologies
cardiaques donc je pense qu'à suite à
son AVC il a dû avoir un problème de
peut-être tout mettre un stent ou des
choses comme ça
donc oui j'ai vu comme tout le monde le
le roi
surtout pas qu'il se passe quelque chose
qui a un problème donc on se couvre on
le parapluie et on met des voitures on
met des motards en se disant que que
c'est bien comme ça bon voilà c'est
c'est
alors le juge d'instruction a pris la
décision là il y a quelques minutes de
lever la détention provisoire et donc
symboliquement de remettre en liberté
Pierre Palmade aujourd'hui pour raison
médicale ça veut dire proprement noter
les spectateurs pour moi qui pour raison
médicale c'est ça veut dire quoi il est
libre là ça veut dire quoi alors il est
libre il est libre pour l'instant il est
il est hospitalisé donc de toute façon
il va passer il va pas aller loin bien
sûr mais techniquement s'il était guéri
et sur pied il pourrait sortir de
l'hôpital et rentrer chez lui sauf à ce
qu'on lui met un un bracelet
électronique mais ça reviendrait à le
replacer en détention et je pense que à
force de jouer au ping-pong on finit par
s'y perdre
c'est c'est elle est incroyable c'est le
le parcours
juriste judiciaire de Pierre Palmade et
c'est du jamais vu on l'incarçait on le
libère on le fait on sait plus où on en
est et là le parquet de Melun qui est à
l'origine avait demandé la détention de
Pierre Palmade alors là c'est plus c'est
justement fait appel il a fait un
resserrer des tensions alors qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire
qu'ils veulent remettre en prison donc
on comprend pas parce qu'en fait c'est
quoi il y a juste d'instruction qui dit
il faut pas le mettre en prison
qui depuis le début
pense que Pierre Palmade doit être en
détention ne cède pas une nouvelle fois
le procureur revient à la charge et dit
non je conteste et donc il y aura une
décision très rapide dans les quelques
jours je crois que c'est 48 heures voilà
pour regarder avec Valérie 48 heures
pour savoir si effectivement c'est la
juge d'instruction ou le procureur qui
entre guillemets l'emporte dans cette
étape alors c'est bon signe pour lui si
je puis dire que la juge d'instruction
pour raison de santé
va y mettre un terme à cette détention
certes c'est pour raison de santé mais
ça veut aussi dire sans doute qu'elle
estime que pour l'avancée du dossier il
n'a pas besoin d'aller en prison et ça
ça peut être un bon signe pour lui c'est
sûr que ces avocats ont plaidé pour ça
auprès de la juge c'est certain donc
aujourd'hui il repasse donc en contrôle
judiciaire avec brasserie électronique
depuis l'hôpital pas forcément même pas
non non parce que le bracelet c'est une
forme de détention alors là on l'a
libéré quand il est sous contrôle
judiciaire c'est aussi je ne sais pas
les termes du contrôle judiciaire mais
peut-être pointer une fois par semaine
en 2016
on est dans une histoire
ça pourrait être un sketch si c'était
pas aussi grave
d'une espèce de petite guéguerre entre
le parquet et le juge instruction on
s'aperçoit quand même que c'est très
lourd à gérer au quotidien de d'avoir un
détenu avec des gardes avec des qu'il
faut le l'emmener quelque part vous avez
vu les images ces trois motards quatre
motards SIM motards deux voitures de
police donc je pense que la décision de
le remettre en liberté en l'état n'est
pas une mauvaise décision face une
décision intelligente elle est pleine de
bon sens cette décision
il existe pourtant des cellules
médicalisées il existe pourtant des
cellules médicalisées
mais apparemment ça pathologie relève
est plus grave la marinade longue c'est
c'est la chirurgie cardiaque aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on dit c'est c'est toujours
un détenu
d'être sûr c'est sûr donc ça veut dire
si là voilà il sortait de l'hôpital pour
rentrer chez lui voilà sauf si il a une
décision contraire
il faut attendre le référé le référé des
tensions du du parquet de Melun mais là
tout de suite la juge d'instruction a
levé la mesure de de
détention d'accord donc là voilà donc là
quand on lève la décision il y a plus de
elle peut la reprendre aussi d'ailleurs
elle pas à tout moment on peut le
réincarrer mais incarcéré quelqu'un pour
le mettre à l'hôpital ça a pas de sens
bien sûr voilà donc je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faut non mais c'est
symboliquement pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent les 21h04 là on est
en direct donc là ça vient de tomber
donc c'est vraiment on avait même pas
prévu le sujet ça vient de tomber
puisque la détention provisoire de
Pierre Palmade lever pour médical pour
les téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
pour eux ils se disent donc là à l'heure
qu'il est à l'instant T vous êtes sûr
parce que il y a des gens qui disent
tout et leur contraire vous êtes sûr que
pour l'instant là il est considéré comme
libre il est plus en détention donc
quand on est plus en détention on lève
la mesure des tensions donc il est plus
en détention donc il est plus en prison
donc il est libre il est important donc
il pourrait récupérer son portable il
peut normalement oui puisqu'il est libre
maintenant je vous rappelle quand même
qu'il est hospitalisé
et rien n'empêche le juge d'instruction
et c'est peut-être ça le switch à tout
moment de le replacer en détention
d'accord sauf que on libère les
policiers il y en avait un ici l'autre
jour qui se plaignait parce qu'ils
avaient pu d'effectif que ça ça leur
prenait un temps fou la patrouille de
police la voiture les les fonctionnaires
etc là on a levé tout ça d'accord donc
il est tout seul dans sa chambre
d'hôpital et libre de non
peut avoir les visites une personne va
venir l'attaquer je pense pas
sa famille peut aller le boire
tranquille d'accord il est libre OK et
donc si il est pas si dans sa bouche pas
une fois qu'il est plus libre il va
pouvoir donc entrer chez lui bah écoutez
oui sauf parce que ça aurait été pareil
pour une personne lambda ou pas du tout
j'ai du mal à vous répondre à cette
question parce que
les gens qui sont dans la situation de
Pierre Palmade qui s'appelle pas Pierre
Palmade ne vont pas en prison en général
suite un accident de la route quand il y
a un mort malheureusement ils ne vont
pas en prison donc pierre Palma on dit
qu'il a un régime de faveur c'est pas
vraiment un film de faveur c'est un
régime de défaveur c'est un peu un
régime un peu dur quand même puisque on
incarcère pas les gens en général qui
ont un accident mortel de la route et
Pierre Palma dont on veut l'incarrer bon
ceci il a pas fait une journée de prison
jusqu'à présent oui c'est une première
étape qui pour lui aujourd'hui là c'est
une première victoire judiciaire on va
dire mais ça peut être provisoire parce
que peut-être que ça a été levé Cyril
parce que son état de santé nécessite là
une vraie intervention qui n'est pas
compatible avec la détention donc il y a
un éventuel caractère provisoire à
double titre d'abord voir l'évolution de
son état de santé et voir l'appel mais
c'est sûr que il y a un côté
inapplicable à long terme dans cette
détention là où il était au vu c'était à
Villejuif au début on disait c'est une
passoire il peut pas rester là
effectivement les policiers comme
disaient Michel qui sont venus là disent
mais on peut pas pendant des semaines
maintenir comme ça quelqu'un se
surveillance inadapté ce qu'on nous dit
là c'est que ils ont décidé donc de
lever la détention provisoire de
l'humoriste pour raison médicale mais le
procureur a fait un référé des tensions
il reste donc sous-écrou jusqu'à
l'audience de vendredi
mais c'est pas du tout l'information
qu'on a puisque on nous dit que le juge
a levé la détention alors Michel je me
demande regardez Valérie on se demandait
s'il appelle
suspensive de la décision
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un côté
provisoire même dans l'exécution de la
décision de la juge d'instruction
parce qu'il y a énormément parce que là
je pense que c'est ça
qui est énormément de gens qui
réagissent là sur les sur les réseaux et
qui disent que c'est inadmissible qui
soit libre voilà ou quoi mais décision
définitive je pense dans les 48 heures
c'est ça
examiner quatre jours en 4 jours à 4
jours exactement dans la manière dont
elle est présentée c'est qu'on a
l'impression que son état de santé a
moins de riz la gravité des faits alors
que ça n'a rien à voir ça veut dire quoi
que si vous n'avez pas fait d'AVC il
aurait été en détention provisoire c'est
ça ah c'est ça oui il aurait le parquet
avait au départ on le laisse libre sous
bracelet électronique ensuite il y a cet
AVC et puis maintenant ce a priori ce
petit problème cardiaque et on lève la
détention probablement pour pour des
raisons de commodité et il présente
aucun danger à la société en étant
hospitalisé après tout ce qui vient de
subir sur un plan médical et s'il rentre
chez lui dans quelques semaines ça veut
dire alors il peut se re-droguer par
exemple et oui sans doute rien ne dit
qu'il va rentrer chez lui rien ne
préjuge ce qui va se passer dans 48
heures
avec le resserrer des tensions demandées
par le procureur de Melun
maintenant pendant ces 48 heures il n'y
a pas de garde il y a pas de les
policiers sont pas sont pas sur ces
devants la porte de sa chambre et parce
que c'est pas forcément utile alors
juste il sait pas ce qu'il était sous
stupéfiant qu'il a été aussi qui devait
être incarcéré dans c'est ça oui alors
sous l'emprise de stupéfiant non oui
absolument parce qu'il y avait cette
idée de récidivelégal qui figure
d'ailleurs dans la mise en examen voilà
récidive légal et puis sous après avoir
pris des stupéfiants donc il y a tout ça
et il y avait cette idée aussi de ce
sevrage progressif dont on ignore où il
en est et peut-être que parce que
c'était la grande théorie de ces avocats
c'était nécessité d'un lieu où il serait
sous sevrage pour se soigner et depuis
le début ces avocats Martel ça ils
avaient construit un plan etc peut-être
que là la juge a été sensible au delà de
son état de santé à leurs arguments
disant regardez il va se sevrer on vous
l'assure il faut qu'il continue ce
processus et les tensions n'est
peut-être pas compatible avec ça en fait
c'est vraiment un jeu de pouvoir là
exactement entre la juge qu'il a c'est
un peu le procureur qui revient à la
charge et on aura dans donc vendredi une
réponse définitive si jamais la
détention est levée là ça veut dire
clairement on peut le dire que le
dossier considéré alors à trois raisons
encore une fois les victimes vont hurler
légitimement que le dossier est
considéré comme moins lourd pour lui
qu'il ne l'a été initialement si jamais
la détention est levée au-delà de l'état
de santé franchement je pense qu'on
pourra dire ça mais oui Michel je pense
aussi que la décision de la chambre de
l'accusation a peut-être été aussi un
peu influencé par le volley pélope
pornographique qui dont elle n'avait pas
à traiter on avait a priori pas à
connaître mais
qu'elle a par la force des choses elle a
eu connaissance de ce vol en quoi ça
impacter pour noter les spectateurs
c'est
je pense que la chambre de l'instruction
quand elle décide de le mandat de dépôt
sur la détention elle se dit bon il y a
la drogue l'accident mortel et
maintenant la pédophilie
on va taper un petit coup quoi c'est un
peu comme ça même si ils sont pas saisis
ce volet là il doit être entendu malgré
tout dans la ferme même si on a trouvé
autre chose
jusqu'à preuve il y a plus bien sûr donc
là en résumé donc là il est il est pas
encore libre puisqu'il y a une ça a été
appelle suspensif et vendredi il pourra
peut-être être libre exactement
pour lui voilà donc si vendredi il est
libre qu'il est plus qu'il doit plus
être à l'hôpital il rentre chez nous oui
parce que le procureur
tenez satisfaction une fois il est pas
du tout ça qu'il obtienne satisfaction
deux fois et sans doute faudra-t-il
trouver un lieu où il pourra continuer
son processus de soins à voir si c'est
dans un cadre médical aussi chez lui et
jugé propice
c'est pas obligé ça veut dire qu'il peut
il veut le juge il peut dire il peut
rendre chez lui et puis on verra après
ou pas du tout mais juste je peux
décider le juge peut décider de dire il
n'y a plus de raison de le maintenir
dans un milieu syndicalisé ça ce serait
vraiment étonnant parce que alors là ce
serait quasiment entre guillemets une
première victoire absolue pour la
diction
plutôt continuer le sevrage et le
processus de soins longtemps des
semaines qui était la première décision
et qui était à mon avis pas la plus
mauvaise donc aujourd'hui on se dirige
quoi vers un processus de soins pour
permettre
des tensions c'est quand même un garçon
qui se qui prend des produits depuis
qu'il a 20 ans il y en a 54
il est lourdement touché par ce ce
problème la famille des victimes elle
doit être terrible ne serait-ce que la
symbolique alors certes il y a un appel
mais c'est pour ça que ça réagit dans
ben évidemment la symbolique honnêtement
quand on a appris la décision c'est le
choc entre guillemets je vais traduire
ça de manière très simple c'est Pierre
Palma est libre voilà tout ce qu'on a
compris en alors c'est pas tout à fait
ça c'est pas tout à fait pas ça non plus
traduit en langage de la vie quotidienne
des gens c'est Palma est libre après
tout ce qu'il a fait donc ça pose quand
même énormément de questions
il a pas été condamné la détention
préventive provisoire elle est pas
obligatoire en plus la question avant et
je repose une dernière fois est-ce que
ça aurait été la même chose pour
n'importe qui
c'est compliqué de répondre à cette
question
je peux dire la faire Palmade elle a
fait beaucoup de mal aux familles qui
ont été justement victimes d'accidents
de la route sous cannabis sous alcool et
que les gens n'ont pas fait une journée
en prison à la fait énormément de mal à
toutes ces familles là qui ont été
touchées par des drames parce que il n'a
pas une journée en prison alors quid de
la première fois qu'on m'a on nous a dit
faut pas qu'il reste tout seul parce que
ça va atteindre à sa santé si celui-ci
qu'est-ce qui se passe où sont les deux
mecs qui étaient dans la maison où sont
les deux mecs qui sont sauvés allez
quand même bizarre cette histoire
Palmade on va revenir là-dessus hein
Michel aura l'occasion de revenir en
tout cas l'info de dernière minute c'est
celle-ci